y la llama olímpica pertenece
oficialmente a china en una ceremonia en
atenas el vicepresidente del comité
olímpico chino aceptó la antorcha de uno
de los miembros del comité olímpico
internacional
[Aplausos]
la llama olímpica está lista para
comenzar su largo viaje desde atenas a
china para llegar al estadio olímpico de
beijing para la ceremonia de apertura de
la edición 24 de los juegos olímpicos de
invierno está previsto que la llama
llegue este miércoles a la capital
asiática antes de embarcarse en una gira
por china hasta la ceremonia de apertura
del evento el 4 de febrero pero el
símbolo del olimpismo no llega sin
polémica muchos defensores de los
derechos humanos han llamado a las
justas los juegos del genocidio
activistas que denunciaban abusos de
derechos humanos en china irrumpieron en
el complejo arqueológico donde se
celebró la ceremonia de encendido de la
llama el lunes los manifestantes
cuestionan las duras políticas de
beijing en el tíbet taiwán la represión
de las protestas en hong kong y su
maltrato a los vigor es una minoría
musulmana que habita en el nororiente de
china de speyer snow
reig este comportamiento no sólo es
escandaloso es inmoral y criminal es
esencialmente una cuestión de ayudar a
asistir y alentar al régimen de beijing
a llevar a cabo su propaganda y encubrir
lo de etapa con belleza su genocidio no
debemos permitir que esto suceda a pesar
de las denuncias el presidente del
comité olímpico internacional rechazó
los llamados al boicot defendiendo la
neutralidad política de la instancia en
su intento por adquirir legitimidad
beijing será una vez más sede de unos
olímpicos y se convertirá en esta
ocasión en la primera ciudad en la
historia olímpica en organizar unos
juegos de verano y de invierno